a florida man is using the war in  ukraine as an excuse to try to speed a  man in florida was found to be going 50  in a 30 mile per hour zone he gave the  deputy that pulled him over several  different reasons for why he was  speeding he claimed that he was trying  to get his car out of sport mode and he  was trying to get ahead of another  driver by the way both of those excuses  are complete bunk there have been lots  of cases where people have claimed that  their cruise control was malfunctioning  and that's why they were speeding that  always gets rejected because speeding is  basically a strict liability crime but  here the particular excuse was  particularly interesting because he  finally broke down and told the truth  which is quote i just found out that  putin said he was going to launch  nuclear thermal war against the world  and i was trying to get back to my house  to find out what's going on well sorry  florida man even in an apocalypse you're  still guilty of speeding